في الأسبوع الماضي فقط علمنا بأول
استخدام معروف ناجح
لنظام صواريخ باتريوت في أوكرانيا
لاعتراض صاروخ روسي وارد
وفقًا للبنتاغون ،
استخدم الأوكرانيون نظام صواريخ باتريوت
لاعتراض صاروخ كينسال أو كيلجوي وهو
صاروخ فرط صوتي واحد من
الصواريخ الروسية الأعلى حدًا ، وهي عبارة عن
صاروخ باليستي يتم إطلاقه من الجو ، وهو
نظام قوي ومتطور من روسيا
رأيناه يستخدم لأول مرة
طوال الحرب في أوكرانيا ، والآن
نعرف ما الذي كان الروس
يستهدفونه ووفقًا لـ  اثنان من
المسؤولين الأمريكيين - كان الروس يستهدفون
نظام صواريخ باتريوت نفسه في محاولة
للتخلص من أحد الأنظمة الأكثر تقدمًا
إن لم يكن النظام الأكثر تقدمًا الذي
قدمته الولايات المتحدة لأوكرانيا ، وهو
نظام دفاع جوي قوي بعيد المدى لا توفره الولايات المتحدة فحسب ، بل
أيضًا.  قدمت ألمانيا وهولندا أيضًا
بعض المكونات التي تمنح أوكرانيا
نظامي صواريخ باتريوت
للدفاع الجوي بعيد المدى وفقًا
لمسؤولين أمريكيين على دراية بالموضوع ، حيث
كان الروس يحاولون
إخراج النظام نفسه إلى Cripple أو
تدمير أحد أقوى الطائرات الجوية.
أنظمة الدفاع وأنظمة الدفاع الجوي بعيدة المدى
التي تمتلكها أوكرانيا ولكن
أوكرانيا أطلقت عدة صواريخ باتريوت
لاعتراض صاروخ كينزال أو
صاروخ كيلجوي وتدميره قبل أن
يتمكن من تدمير النظام نفسه مما يسمح
لأوكرانيا بالحفاظ على واحدة من
أطول مداها وأكثرها قوة.
أنظمة الدفاع كيف
عرفت روسيا مكان وجود النظام بعد أسابيع فقط من
وصوله إلى البلاد بشكل جيد ،
يستخدم نظام صواريخ باتريوت
رادارًا قويًا لاكتشاف التهديدات القادمة من
مسافة بعيدة تمامًا كما يمكن للولايات المتحدة وأوكرانيا
اكتشاف رادارات العدو ، وكذلك يمكن
لروسيا  اكتشاف المكان الذي
يأتي منه هذا الصاروخ أو هذا الانبعاث تقريبًا ،
وبمجرد أن يكون لديهم إحساس عام بالمكان الذي يعتمد عليه
نظام باتريوت على أساس
الرادار الذي ينبعث منه ، يمكنهم استخدام الأقمار الصناعية
والأنظمة الأخرى لمحاولة التركيز على
ذلك ومحاولة استهدافه  لكن
باتريوت الذين يتعلمون هذا النظام يتعلمون
الباتريوت أسرع بكثير مما كان
متوقعًا لعدة أشهر فقط بدلاً
من عام حيث يمكنهم استخدام
صاروخ باتريوت نفسه للدفاع عن
بطارية باتريوت من هذا الهجوم القادم أو في
ليبرمان سي إن إن في البنتاغون